beauté on a interdit les concours de
minimis c'est peut-être mieux pour l'ego
de Mimie Mathy
et maintenant j'accueille Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
C'est pas Hollande qui disait qui
comptait sur une défaite de Merkel au
législative oui
[ __ ] de visionnaire
quand il se retira de la politique
pourra toujours faire l'horoscope sur
RTL
a bien gagné bon c'est un triomphe mais
ça pas été le fasse non plus quoi les
bosses c'est plus que c'était c'est pas
pas de parade sur les champs personne
rue Lauriston je me sentais bien seul au
Lutetia
à propos de guerre hey patoche enfin
pardon monsieur mellucci
ça n'a pas été trop dur de traverser les
checkpoints que tiennent les shebabs des
quartiers nord de Marseille pour
non parce que c'est fou en trois heures
TGV Paris Marseille était en zone libre
enfin ça doit faire quelque chose de
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas pour votre demande de tout à
l'heure en coulisse il y a pas de
problème je vais signer votre gilet par
balle c'est pas de
à Marseille mars parler de Marseille
Vieux tous les excès Marseille vous le
savez c'est cette mosaïque de diversité
de différence de non similitudes
d'antithèses de contradiction de
disparité de disproportion de
dissemblance de dissimilitude de
distance de distinction des quarts
d'hétérogénéité d'un compatibilité
d'inégalité de nuances de variétés et là
ça reste mon dictionnaire des synonymes
emploi
alors il paraît que l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage est en train de se
produire c'est grâce aux emplois jeunes
mais c'est une très bonne idée alors moi
je suis allé sur le site des emploisiens
il y a des témoignages extraordinaires
c'est aussi un travail de journaliste
c'est pas que de la bouffonnerie il y a
attention témoignage de Cindy après
plusieurs missions de nettoyage la
Mission Locale du propose une formation
MHL maintenant et hygiène des locaux
suivi d'une formation SST Sauveur
secouriste du travail c'est vachement
bien surtout qu'une fois que tu as les
deux diplômes tu peux fusionner les
formations MHL et SST pour obtenir un
diplôme MST
autre exemple parce qu'il y a plusieurs
emplois bien sûr elle a entendu alors
Jean si on va prendre un nom d'emprunt
après une semaine d'essai au sein de la
mairie Jean a fait l'unanimité et s'ils
sont contrat dans la foulée et là ainsi
déjà participé à plusieurs formations
l'une sur le fonctionnement des
collectivités locales et l'autre sur le
déplacement des emails
classement des emails métiers d'avenir
considérable attention c'est que le
début on prévoit aussi des métiers comme
éboueur de corbeille Windows
redémarreur de PC
manutentionnaire de la touche caps lock
c'est
sur PC parce que sur Mac c'est une autre
formation
il y a pas que ça ce qui compte aussi
c'est des métiers d'avenir liés à la
sensibilisation aux écogestes animations
conseils des choses extraordinaires des
alors tout ça c'est vrai ambassadeur des
économies d'eau
à quoi tiens
il y a aussi ambassadeur de la
prévention des déchets
tout vous ne représentation dans un
local poubelle et puis tu
sais pas enfin c'est pas moi alors
j'attends encore le grand chambellan du
plus molectrostatique ou le ministre
délégué au trace calcaire enfin c'est
très
à Michel Sapin il devrait pas faire
ministre de l'Emploi mais chef de fil
des nouveaux poètes quoi c'est pas le
successeur de DSK mais de Salvador Dali
Rome Mania oui en ce moment les Roms tu
as l'impression que c'est les Spice
Girls
les Roms qui sont pourtant très utiles à
la France contrairement à tous c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable il
souligne les gaspillages de France
Télévisions bah oui pourquoi laisser
Frédéric Lopez emmener des acteurs à
l'autre bout de la terre avec des moyens
considérables alors qu'il suffit de
passer la porte de la chapelle pour
vivre une aventure humaine hors du
commun
[Applaudissements]
plutôt que de voir sa bouche et les
Inuits du détroit de Bering nous restons
pas de voir Jean Roucas chez les Roms de
la bretelle de Sarcelles
mais bon il faut que les rhums reste
lucides c'est engouement ses provisoires
c'est un effet de mode ça peut pas durer
c'est fragile Rome sachez une chose vous
n'allez pas vivre longtemps sur vos
acquis vos privilèges
après valse a dérape et c'est sûr il a
dit les Roms on vocation à rester en
Roumanie en Bulgarie alors déjà leur
dire de partir c'est pas facile mais en
plus les humilier en leur expliquant
qu'ils ne méritent pas mieux que le
Bangladesh européen psychologie
message d'espoir pour toutes les
familles qui ont un proche dans une
secte avec de la volonté on peut s'en
sortir merci à toi pour cette leçon de
courage Noël ma mère
communication Matignon a recruté une
conseillère en communication pour Madame
Hérault alors ça commence à porter ses
fruits il paraît qu'elle est très à
l'aise avec la méthode syllabique
amour alors un Yéménite est mort après
avoir bouffé 5 pilules de Viagra alors
qu'ils se préparer pour sa nuit de noces
on l'a retrouvé mort sous ce que l'on
croyait être une tente
dans la même veine
un Colombien de 66 ans a été amputé de
la verge car il avait surdosé le Viagra
érection qui a duré 5 jours boom la
gangrène alors tout n'est pas perdu
puisque avec la peau abandonnée par
l'homme on pourra reconstituer l'organe
de la femme
parce que 5 jours enfin voilà quoi
beauté on a interdit les concours de
minimis c'est peut-être mieux pour l'ego
de Mimie Mathy
musique Patrick Bruel siffler et hué par
35000 personnes lors de l'inauguration
d'un nouveau stade à Nice ce qui enlève
quelques préjugés sur les Niçois ils ont
peut-être la gâchette facile mais au
moins c'est d'aimer
alors une bonne nouvelle de la semaine
peut-être on vient de trouver une tonne
3 de cocaïne dans un avion à Paris
malgré ce coup dur saluons le courage
des organisateurs d'avoir pu tout de
même maintenir la Fashion Week alors ma
belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu